it would support me maybe I don't think
about it I could do is American accident
when he speaks English all right good no
it's not one of these days oh he should
collab with the Chili Peppers the kids
stuff I can't you know I bet he can rap
some Chili Peppers oh yeah
anyway we're gonna watch a topper warty
request if it's not Natalie Doran it's
gonna be Laura more Laura yeah sexy
devil you do not tweet me for saying
that I am sorry you're not the devil
when I can edit this out BTS attack on
bangtan live oh there are not attacked
my boys hey guys at our patreon page we
do a lot of things but the most
important thing you've got to know it's
John hmmm he does music video reactions
one day out of every month weekly page
and a lot of time its kpop yeah like a
puffin that's probably the most abundant
kind that's right every once in a while
John's like I'm gonna branch out and do
more of the indie artists that I love no
no I've can then no more don't get fused
[Music]
[Music]
my TV
[Music]
yes I am always yeah yeah okay
[Music]
I've seen I've seen so much about you
guys
do that girls have fun turn it up
look
they're bit maintained boys on the March
[Music]
damn
[Music]
yes
[Music]
it's supposed to be jump as harder jump
as hot both and I'm gonna like smash
down in the ground
[Music]
this is like the perfect song for a
crowd
[Music]
you could have been there don't we keep
you so cool
so cool here you guys can see what's
recommended to us based on what we watch
so we've got massive pop remixes she is
live corridor crew looks like we really
like red letter media a lot and there's
a little Jensen Ackles Jenny what's
hosted oh yeah listen to this song a
Jensen Ackles performed phantom
entertainment of course you gotta love
these actors on actors YouTube is a
great platform they got a lot of
different videos of a lot of different
kind love this channel up in heaven
music they have so many great songs
they're like remixes that are like four
trailers
beyond that what I was thinking the
whole time I was watching that was they
probably be a lot more comfortable if
they weren't wearing those clothes it's
very hard to perform in formal clothing
with the amount of dancing they do they
have the perfect mix and I don't know if
I've said this before because it really
hit me when I was watching this being a
boy band and being badass rappers
usually don't go together normally it's
like rappers make fun of boy pants and
it's pretty crazy to see how they have
like fluidly mesh that cuz I'm like
listening to them and even if I don't
know what they're saying let's say there
were no subtitles I don't feel like I
need to always hear the lyrics because I
think with something like rap especially
a lot of beats yes I think that's why
BTS has become so universal even if you
don't speak their language even if you
don't have the chance to read along with
English subtitles attached I think
they're become universal because their
emotion is always communicated and felt
and I think with a rapping that's
especially important there's plenty of
rap songs where they're going so fast I
don't know what they're saying but I'm
like
dude comes through in the emotion of the
lyrics and the tone of the beaten supply
yeah I mean you have three underground
rappers and then four hop idols you know
married together to form this group so
it is a perfect synthesis by only 14
parents until that's absolutely the case
at least 14 you never know that's true
RM was conceived in a pop lab yes right
people realize that it's a genetically
engineered
yeah our Jurassic Park they're like we
took DNA out of this rapper that way
yeah this dancer and this pop stone a
cuttlefish
and all that and they were like what if
RM starts to mate and have babies and
they're like he can't have baby yeah
because you know engineered clones are
sterile and then they found six other
eggs which became the PT yeah but see
this is the thing is pretty soon we're
gonna get tired and we're gonna need an
even bigger crazier version of BTS so
they're gonna have to go back to the
drawing board start manipulating even
more maybe add like an MMA element to
the show so much you can do here I think
this is a problem that we've been
watching so much BTS because now I'm
under the illusion that if I met them
I'd feel like they are my friends I know
right you would you would know each
individually you would have memories
formed with them they would never know
about it we've watched so much more than
that I don't think our most viewed thing
is a music video or a performance I'm
pretty sure it's like watching one other
interviews ain't and dinner party or
yeah I like that is chatting for an hour
right the fandom runs deep so I'm really
concerned that I will have the fortunate
pleasure meeting that would that I will
just be awkward and be like you don't
you have no idea who I am and I am so
much less than each of you individually
well as long as you just be yourself and
be genuine with them and don't try to be
something you're not don't be a crow to
hit they won't let me directly I can't
be myself John uh well you know their
dating history is kept pretty under
wraps so you never know what could
happen you know clandestine behind
closed doors away from paparazzi and
kind of look down that could all seven
be homosexual no and then you would have
to choose and it'd be a whole other
dilemma
would be a hole their level of pain but
if they're all gay they wouldn't have 14
parents the joke is not that I'm
homophobic the joke is the idea of
satire that you show kitties don't get
all the sexuality for teen parents
they're all the same gender that's how
it works anyway we've we've gained a lot
of ground with the BTS army this is
gonna be our top lady halfway through
the reaction when they notice that we
had to cut it because they're like hey I
saw another channel they didn't cut it
up at all well good for them the rules
are don't know why we get blocked all
the time either loosely and unevenly
enforced here on YouTube just ask
everybody who tried to react to the
mandalorian recently I did love this
performance man oh yeah I remember when
this happened this is actually right
next door I called the cops and I said
hey there's a lot of noise going on at
the Staples I really I know that I I
kind of signed up for this because rent
is 500 bucks to live next to the Staples
Center beneath the Staples Center it's
been very loud yeah and that's why we
over sometimes late to certain reactions
because well there's no why do much
noise down there or there's no Wi-Fi too
it's really rough guys subscribe rejects
click that notification Bell check us
out on patreon where we do q and A's TV
show reactions to me belong some
reaction highlights included he covers a
music video once a year let's give a
shout out a proper one to Laura Moore
now Laura I found out is barista
at Starbucks steamy where she always has
to deal with all kinds of customers now
Laura from my understanding if you are a
woman working behind any counter you're
gonna get hit on by some male customers
right now I don't know if you're married
I don't know if you have a boyfriend or
a girlfriend or you know an inanimate
object you're romantically attached to
but I will say this the easiest way to
find it the right soulmate for you if
someone is hitting on you in line all I
would do is start quoting a line don't
go
do you know BTS just say a quote from
one of the lyrics one of their popular
ones and then if they go listen to BTS
and you know you found the right one
meant to be but if they're like txt you
got to throw that coffee right in their
face there's only one kpop ban on this
channel and if they're like hey can I
get your name for when your orders ready
and if they say anything like Fred
Flintstone
no oh no no that guy's a creep no